yeah this is about right let's make it
there this house doesn't remove you back
oh wait just have socks very funky keep
your socks right here
there she is Miss America hi friends I
don't know what I'm doing for this video
she said before every video ever made hi
guys I'm in Montreal Canada right now
I'm adjust for Laughs comedy festival
mamrie and I are hosting a show called
all exes live to show Thursday night
here come to them if you didn't watch
this in time stop just kidding gently
with purpose everything in life that you
do do it with purpose even if it is yeah
this hairstyles pretty representative of
where I'm at right now I trace on
Twitter what kind of video you want to
see and a lot of you said a lot of
different things that were not able to
be done in a hotel room but a lot of you
said stream-of-consciousness video which
I say thank God because I can do that in
a hotel room I do that every day of my
life everywhere i stream my
consciousness but mostly in my own brain
calm ha music let's talk about
everything and anything
this shirt does this and I don't like
that that's better I don't need the
lines to be like you have boobs so let
me get my phone because I'm a millennial
I'm without it I'm helpless Oh found it
crisis averted that was intense let's
see what's going on in the world okay
listen I know I talked really shishi
about Pokemon go but I've been Pokemon
going and I think I'm Pokemon gone I
can't stop wanting to catch them all the
new Smash Mouth song threw people off
hearing that Smash Mouth has a new song
it's throwing me off let's look at this
life-size Lego costume is the stuff of
nightmares what Oh No but I'm gonna look
at it no no why is it like that why does
it look like human skin stretched over a
Lego I guess that happened at Comic Con
how was your Comic Con okay this is
going well you guys wanna see some of
the art that this hotel room has to
offer but um erm art is hugely
underappreciated so let me just show you
what we've got going for us by the way
this is your tripod thank you to the
Bible or helping us out they seem to
help a lot of people in a lot of
different ways and myself included here
we have
Wow this speaks to me because I think I
can make this you know and art should
start a conversation about if it's
better than you or not and this is not
better than me
same with that I see they're going for a
theme here very up close images of
corners of buildings which makes me
think that the building itself must be
extremely ugly you know like when tinder
profile pictures are super cropped in
because something's clearly wrong with
the rest of the person what's going on
with these buildings huh
oh here's art this is when someone
clearly doesn't know how to crop their
profile photo who are you trying to crop
out of your photo building who you got
in there this is dynamic and interesting
I went to New York I caught a Pikachu
and I caught it when I was laying in bed
in my hotel room so you don't have to go
far to achieve your dreams you just have
to sometimes suck it up and spend your
own money on incense in the pokey store
and just you gotta spend money to make
Pikachu's feels weirdly like
prostitution like I'm spending this
money and then all of a sudden they're
showing up and I'm catching them maybe
that's not the right analogy but it's
always fun when room service comes in
well you have your camera open on top of
a Bible on top of the desk
you guys want a hotel room tour let's do
it doctors that is that is that is that
is my hair extension novella earlier
when I was in the shower Wow
I mean this video is dynamic app who
knew she was so good at music what you
guys got going on for August August
feels like a month that no one has any
strong opinions about huh do they what's
August every month I feel like has a
personality in August is like August all
getting ready for school
you guys getting ready for school here's
some tips for going back to school go to
school try your best none of the things
that seem terrible about it will
actually matter compared to the even
more terrible crises don't have later in
your life don't text nudes great
back-to-school tip I had vegan poutine
today judge me I'm not bragging because
it destroyed my digestion took them in
there went in and just Montreal's Barry
French over here extensions of fauna
little by little that's gonna be a real
roller coaster ride at this show
tomorrow
up here comes one is one actually just
falling out right now oh boy oh no oh no
I've reached a whole new level of trash
today I knew today was gonna be an
important day
I just didn't know exactly how ok well
that seems like the right time to wrap
up this video thank you guys so much for
watching if you enjoyed this video
subscribe to this YouTube channel if you
did not enjoy this video subscribe to
this YouTube channel cuz I could I could
use some I could use some support
it's a little sticky so always recycle
thanks for watching I don't know this
makes me feel like some sort of guru
that maybe does know
no my hair extension fell out and I
taped it to my chin clearly I don't know